be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so have a release a couple of videos
criticizing some of the decisions made
by Marvel with regards to the all-new
all-different lineup I wanted to take
some time to highlight what I consider
to be some of their best decisions and
in this video we're gonna be focusing on
RiRi Williams the new iron men so having
been around since March of 1963 Tony
Stark's the legacy within the comic
landscape is huge that's one of the
founding members of the Avengers and
having had incredibly well-written
stories like demon in a bottle by David
Nicolini and Bob Layton Tony Stark has
stood the test of time as one of the
most important characters of Marvel's
lineup while comic fans knew him
extremely well based on his long-running
solo series and time on the Avengers
team as well as his own smaller
ancillary teams like force works Stark
didn't really come to the limelight of
non comic readers until the Civil War
event and the Iron Man film as a result
the history of starch saw
Transformations designed to bring his
character closer in line with how he was
viewed both in the movies and in the
eyes of the general public that said
where Tom Taylor superior Iron Man was
looked at as the jumping off platform
for how stark would be depicted and the
post Secret Wars Marvel landscape
through a combination of social media
and general discussions fans made it
quite clear that because the superior
Iron Man storyline was largely being
ignored and the post Secret Wars
landscape the character of Tony Stark
wasn't coming out is all new and all
different instead his existing history
was simply being rehashed to this end
various fans and I count myself among
that number looked to the overall Iron
Man stories as yet another example of
Marvel's failure to live up to the
all-new all-different brand however this
perception at least in my mind has been
adjusted with the introduction of riri
Williams covered during an interview
with Time magazine titled Marvel's new
Iron Man is a black woman Williams
creator Brian Michael Bendis had stated
that when he took over the Ironman title
he had looked back to his time working
on a television show that never went to
syndication as he explained the plot
involved a young black woman whose life
was immersed in violence who in turn
elevated herself and attended college
considering this to be his definition of
a superhero in the real world the Bendis
retold the concept and degree Williams
first mentioned in passing during
invincible Iron Man issue number one
minutes at ease Williams by having stark
returned to developing new forms of
I'm an armored after his previous models
have been duplicated by an MIT student
using a box of scraps following this her
character remained entirely absent from
the Ironman title until issue number
seven and coming out of the road to
civil war - and centering on an
undercover Stark attending to locate and
subdue an inhuman named Homo who
possessed the power to control
technology using her mind the official
in comic introduction of Williams came
as a kind of backup feature within the
final pages of the invincible Iron Man
title between issue 7 and 11
establishing Williams is a 15 year old
with a genius-level intellect equivalent
to Tony Stark the crossover between the
two was virtually non-existent
Safer Williams developing an Iron Man
suit of her own which lacked the
traditional arc reactor but also took on
a more Japanese animation feel to it in
terms of design following this Williams
exploits were limited to exploring the
capabilities of her newly designed suit
and even going so far as to act and
stark stead due to his well-publicized
absence missing injunction with Marvel
advertised in the new model now lineup
in October depicting Williams as the
cover character for the new Iron Man
series had given way to the notion of
Williams taking over the position under
the blessing of Stark himself and so the
question is this why does riri Williams
highlight everything right with comics
because she's all new and all different
living up to the very essence of what
Marvel's all-new all-different
rebranding was designed to be the
problem with characters like x-23 Miles
Morales Jane Foster and others is that
they don't fall in line with his
ideology
x-23 was designed to be a literal clone
of Wolverine albeit a young girl
spider-gwen Cindy moon and Miles Morales
all received their powers from a spider
bite Jane Foster became thor after
picking up mule near Amadeus Cho
absorbed the essence of the Hulk from
banner and Sam Alexander put on a Nova
Corps helmet in addition to this all the
characters I've just listed are being
touted as heroes taking over existing
legacy characters in the modern outline
but none of the characters are new safer
Cindy moon and spider-gwen Jane Foster
Miles x-23 and all the rest have been
around for years founds in between
stories with Marvel having no idea where
to put them or how to make them
important Williams does not fall into
this category is she's smart like Tony
Stark sure but that hardly makes her a
copy of him you know I know that
East Hank McCoy Reed Richards apocalypse
mr. sinister dr. doom Peter Parker Adam
Beshear Black Panther and Amadeus choke
these are only a handful of characters
ranked among Marvel's smartest beings on
earth
and they all have a level of
intelligence that rivals and exceeds
Tony Stark and they all have their own
individual personalities and concepts
that make them unique in addition to
this Bendis is not paying special
attention to the skin color of Williams
yeah she's black but she's not part of
the all-black superhero team and there's
not one reference in the comics
regarding her skin color and how it
impacts diversity all that comes from a
combination of clickbait news articles
and fans who can't deal with change now
will Williams be relegated to the
position of stark sidekick possibly but
were the comics now following the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and Robert Downey jr.
expected to walk away from his role
after the next several films not only do
I expect to see Williams remain Iron Man
in the comics I actually expect her to
be introduced into the movies as part of
phase four following Robert Downey jr.
departure with that maybe said we're
gonna bring this video to an end and
this is just my little rant my little
spiel on everything that I think is
right with Marvel Comics and I'll catch
you guys later peace